SPEAKER 1: Are you guys ready?
SPEAKER 2: I think we are.
So Damien will come up after me.
I was super excited.
Damien works in the
Munich office here.
We're partnering a lot with
the Bazel team internally
and it's like we
should have something
to mix things up a little
bit, talk about future stuff.
Damien wrote a great talk and I
went through the talk and said,
this is amazing.
It's like, what if someone
went through this talk
and didn't understand
the context of what
we're doing with Dart?
So like maybe we should
add some context.
So I'll do that first.
So I didn't have to
teach Damien about it
all because he's
working on a huge
build system that supports
lots of languages.
So let's look.
This is kind of the forward
to his talk about the Dart web
workflow.
And it's a very touchy clicker.
So we've talked a lot about
the Summit from our customers,
after a second time,
it's great hearing it,
about [INAUDIBLE] how they
have a fast dev cycle.
Obviously, on the
web side they want
to be able to build
for production
and they need to do things
like code generation and code
transformation.
You just need to do that and,
obviously, the great talk
yesterday about source
gen and that type of work
makes it obvious.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
And so we have
solutions for this now.
Right?
We say, use pub, pub
build, pub serve, use
barback transformers.
I talked to people
who've written a bunch
of their own transformers.
This is a really great model.
It's 100% Dart, so
it ships in the box
and it's fast-- well,
if you're using Dartium
and if your app is
on the smaller side
and if you don't have
a lot of transformers.
So when Will and others talked
about how things got kind
of slow, that's what happened.
Because all these things are
built on big global analysis
of things.
We have a need to
do code generation,
you usually want to look at
the analysis of your code.
Doing that big AST or
that big analysis context
takes a long time.
And you have to do it
every time you build.
dart2js does global inference
and it looks at all the code.
And so that takes a long time.
And that's just part
of the problems.
And if you look at what we do
with barback for transformers,
it lets you overwrite files,
which seems nice, but actually
ends up being really bad,
because then if you look
at things like source
maps and stack traces,
does the stack trace point
to the generated file
or my original file?
It's not clear.
If you're doing pub serve,
all the intermediate files
are actually in memory.
So there's actually no
place to look at the source
map and the stack trace.
And obviously, if
you do a pub build,
unless you flip certain
flags, those files
aren't even on disk.
And obviously, every time you
build, you start from scratch
and that can take a long time.
We've had people internally
take many, many minutes.
It's a very long coffee break
for a full build from scratch.
So what's the solution here?
Well, I actually stole a
bunch of these slides from VJ.
Thank you.
I didn't tell him in advance.
He talked about this yesterday
in the dev compiler talk.
Right?
Which is we have many megabytes
of code, complex dependencies,
how do you solve this?
And the way you solve this is--
and obviously, all the things
and compilation of JavaScript
isn't even on this list.
Right?
And even things that aren't
necessarily Dart-specific,
like you can take a proto buff
and turn it into Dart code.
The way we do that is internally
with a system called Bazel.
And so it gives you
amazing parallelism
and it gives you caching.
And guess what?
That's how you do
things quickly.
Like, make solve
this a long time ago.
Right?
And so the idea is you might
want to do a table component.
Part of this is,
well, how do we make
sure we do code gen
on that really fast
and compilation on that?
Oh, well, generate summary
and actually save that summary
to disk.
And then in parallel,
we can do the JS stuff
while we're summarizing it.
And then we can do the
summary of another component
and build that in parallel.
And it ends up that
your main line here, you
used to have to worry about
what your slowest component is
because a lot of this
could be parallelized.
And this is actually
a poor example,
because I see four
parallel threads,
but, you know, if
you have eight cords,
it could be eight things.
And that's only one machine.
So what's beautiful
about the Bazel model
what we use internally
is it's one model.
So the way you
generate summaries,
the way you run source_gen, the
way you do template injection,
even the way you
compile to JavaScript,
they're all one system.
Like the way we
generate JS is just
another build output along
with how we generate summaries.
So we have a single model
for all these things' work.
Everything's on disk,
which means your source
maps and your stack traces,
you can go find those files.
In some cases, they might be
in some weird temp directory.
You don't necessarily
care because you
can debug through it.
It's 100% incremental
even between builds.
All those incremental
outputs are cached.
You can run things in parallel.
It figures out the
build tree and actually
can run things in parallel.
And it's the exact same
model we have internally,
which means you get
all the benefits we do.
When we make fixes and
changes and improve things,
folks that use our
frameworks do the same stuff.
So that all sounds great.
Before you jump into
the Bazel stuff,
I would just say don't panic
if you're using pub today.
These things aren't
going anywhere.
And, in fact, the Angular
story that we give you today,
and you run pub serve
and it runs transformers,
it works great, that exact same
code runs in Bazel internally.
And actually, we have
one copy of things
like the template generator
and the dependency injection
generator.
There's one copy and
it works in both.
And so if you write your
own transformers, let's
talk, because your model
will change a little bit.
We have a bunch of code already
out in public and open source
where you basically
write your code once
and then it can go either to
Bazel and a source gen model
or to transformers.
And if you don't write
your own transformers,
this will just come along and
you'll get all the benefits.
So hopefully I've given you some
context and belayed some fears.
And now we can talk
about Bazel specifically.
So I give you Damien.
[APPLAUSE]
DAMIEN MARTIN-GUILLEREZ:
Thank you.
Do you hear me?
Great.
OK.
So Bazel it's a Google
home built system.
It's called Blaze internally.
So previous speakers talked
that they were [INAUDIBLE] it
for six months.
We were [INAUDIBLE] Bazel
last Blaze for nine years.
So we open sourced Bazel
last year in March of 2015.
The basic for Bazel is we
want a big systems that
is fast and correct.
So we have a motto that is
Fast, Correct, Choose Two.
A question you
might ask yourself
is why Google developed
yet another build system.
So back in 2006, Google
was using makefiles.
And it was using, actually,
a generator to make files.
And it's a problem without
it's obviously a makefile.
That is a very,
very clean makefile
from an open source project.
And it's really
difficult to read.
It's still has a
lot of problems.
It looks a bit like that.
Right?
It's also very slow.
So if you try to build one
of the largest open source
projects out there, the
Android open source platform,
try just to request
a dummy packet,
a packet that does not exist.
Only to do that, it
would take 70 seconds
to load all the
makefile it includes.
And it does not do nothing.
It does not do anything.
So what Blaze wants
to be, it wants
to refer a very nice view, a
very maintainable view of the
build for the user.
And we want some
things that scale
to the billions of line of code
of the Google code repositories
and of course, that's
also compilation
files, because every second
lost for the developer
is money lost because
we pay [INAUDIBLE].
One last thing, we want
the build to be correct.
What does that mean?
That means that if
you ever use makefile,
you'll probably use
to do makeclean.
Right?
We have a saying as the
Blaze team to never,
ever do Blaze clean.
We should never have to do it.
And if you take your
build, take the same input,
put it on some machine
at another time,
you will get the same result.
And that's very important
because that's also a lot
of performance improvement
because we can cache
results of everything.
Bazel, which is the
open source place,
it's basically Blaze that
is done of Google internals.
As built-in support for several
[INAUDIBLE], Java [INAUDIBLE]
but having to modify
the binary to scale-ups,
to various language
doesn't work.
So we have an extension
language and to that, we
have that support.
We also have Go, Java
AppEngine, and many more.
We work on Linux, of course.
We work on OS X and we
know what's on Windows
and we are doing a lot of
work to make Windows on par
with Linux and OS
X. So Linux on OS X
is used by thousands of
developers internally.
And so we're trying to offer
the same experience for Windows.
Of course we want
to be fast, correct,
so we do a lot of
things to help that,
and we would go a
bit deeper into that.
So we do cache.
We run as many parallel
jobs as possible.
We're so [INAUDIBLE] to
make sure that we are not
modifying inputs.
We test for it internally
on the code repository.
So remember the makefile?
This is a BUILD file.
This is what Bazel
takes as input.
So it has high-level
representation of the language.
A bit slow, sorry.
So you describe what
you want to build
as Java library, that library,
and you give them a name
and you basically
declare its dependencies.
And that's all that Bazel needs
to actually perform its jobs.
So thanks to that, it
can be fast, correct.
Let's see what's a
build looks like.
So we run a bunch of tests.
It's running a lot of things.
And runs other test.
That's a clean build,
so it has no information
before running that.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank.
And it does that by
constricting in memory a graph
of all your dependencies.
And once it does that
graph, it can actually
follow up which
dependencies has changed
and run the extra [INAUDIBLE].
It can also construct a
graph of the artifacts
that you need to create from
that graph of dependency
and executes action to
generate source artifact.
So if you re-run the same
build, it actually does nothing.
It just re-run every time
you use the same information
that it runs before.
And it also say
that the last cache
was a test result. And why
can we cache test result?
Because we know we have a
correct behavior [INAUDIBLE].
So if we re-run a
test twice, we don't
need to re-run it another time.
We can just say OK, pass me
false, so it must have passed.
Now, let's see what we do
when we actually touch a file.
So let's touch a file.
So we are not fast at typing.
And yeah, we didn't do anything
because so we touch a file,
we evaluate that everything
in its dependency graph,
but after that, we actually see
that the file doesn't change.
So we don't do anything.
Let's actually modify a file.
So let's start by
modifying just a test.
So it's a leaf, if you think
of the dependency graph.
Let's just ready to
test and hide a command.
And then test again.
Bazel [NON-ENGLISH] So we
were run only a test that says
change and no other actions.
So we don't do
extra work, we just
reduce the work that is needed.
So let's modify our library.
That's not enough
exclamation marks,
so let's add another one.
And then we'll re-run the test.
So we do a bit more.
Note the [INAUDIBLE]
.js compiler.
And we just re-run the two test
that are dependent on that.
So how does it work is when
we do modification, we just
see the actions
that need to re-run,
but does not re-run
the other actions.
Our last one.
This is an extract of the
build of Bazel itself.
Bazel is some [? utility ?]
language system by itself
it's just C++, Java,
Python, Proto Buff,
[? shared. ?] We
have a lot of things.
And the interesting
thing in that is you
can see 200 action running.
So we basically, because we
might end up graph in memory
and we know the dependency.
We can stop the act of running
the action as soon as possible
with being sure that we
don't have problem running
those action in parallel.
So as Kevin mentioned,
what if you don't
want to write Bazel files?
Then you don't have to because
the dev team has come up we
with a buildified generator that
just like generates those build
file, run Bazel, and you will
get the same [INAUDIBLE] model,
and gets the same performance
as that if you are running Bazel
natively.
However, if you want
to use Bazel with Java,
with some other
language, then you
can just start taking the
refractionary [INAUDIBLE]
of the generator, started
doing things in them,
and add some more targets.
That's about all.
Our website is bazel.build.
And thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: So a couple things
to add to be really clear
as far as how Bazel affects
Dart and your work here,
because obviously,
this is very important.
If you look at our
Git repo, you'll
notice there's a
couple projects.
There's Rules, Dart, and Bazel.
We're working on some code here.
We're not ready for you
to use this in production.
It's still very early.
You'll see these Bazel
files and these build files
and these workspace files.
If you're really excited
and curious, go play.
But this is not something
we're supporting.
We try to get
things bootstrapped.
So our goal is to get Angular 2
working externally all the way.
And that means we
have code generation
working, tablet generation,
all those things.
Once we get to that
point, we might go out
and say, go play
with this some more.
But I want to be very clear,
our goal is that if you are just
doing Dart, pure Dart-- we call
it the classic Dart or simple
Dart app, meaning you're not
compiling proto buffs and C++
in the background-- you
guys aren't all doing that.
It's cool and we did
a lot internally.
SPEAKER 1: I do it for funsies.
SPEAKER 2: We really
want Bazel to be
able to be an
implementation detail,
a spectacular implementation
detail that makes things
super fast for you,
but you shouldn't
have to worry about it.
And then the idea is if you want
to grow up and do more things
in the broader sense,
do bigger projects,
do cross-language projects,
then your falldown
will be Bazel,
which means we don't
have to write all these
crazy one-off support for XYZ
and Dart.
Bazel will be the
underlying system.
So if you stay simple Dart, you
get all the benefits of Bazel
and you won't have to learn
Bazel scripting language.
And you'll be able to
upgrade to full Bazel
if you want to do
other awesome things.
And I think current users
are folks like TensorFlow
is a big user of Bazel already.
There's folks taking off with
this and they really like it.
So we have a few
minutes for questions.
Is there anything about Bazel
before we jump to lunch?
Any questions?
Always.
SPEAKER 1: I'll
repeat the question.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So what about CSS files,
images, [INAUDIBLE] change that.
SPEAKER 2: What about CSS files,
images, other binary assets?
DAMIEN MARTIN-GUILLEREZ:
So normally, you
declare dependencies on
those files so we see them.
And we also have I guess we'd
have [? globing ?] so you
don't have to worry.
You just call out your
directory and Bazel will see it.
SPEAKER 2: Basically, if you
just have all these things
need to go to this
directory and that's it,
it'll just be an xcopy.
And then a few other things
that consume those images,
I remember in my previous
web writing days,
if you knew spriting
and stuff, then
you'll see those are my
inputs to my sprite rule,
my sprite target.
And then if you
modify those files,
the sprite target will run and
it will generate new sprite.
And that's really
exciting because you
can imagine oh, there's some
Node thing or some Ruby thing
or some Java thing
that does spriting.
And all you want is, I want
content in this directory
so I can use these sprites.
You can bring in the Java
rule or the whatever rule
for spriting in Java or C++,
drop it into your Bazel field,
and you just run Bazel
build and it'll just work.
AUDIENCE: I was curious about
I think Blaze distributes
across different machines, so
like the CI environment would
be the--
SPEAKER 2: So the
question is, so, does this
work across machines?
DAMIEN MARTIN-GUILLEREZ: Yes.
No.
So we have a prototype
implementation
of the API to talk to a
distributive cluster and we
in the middle of rewriting it
to give a more stable version
of it that we would use, too.
SPEAKER 2: Future.
DAMIEN MARTIN-GUILLEREZ:
So, it's experimental
and it's going to
be stable soon.
SPEAKER 2: So what's
great is you'll have,
at least in the
Dart world, you'll
have a better experience than
you have today on one machine
and then all the
future work that Bazel
does in any of those paths,
you just get for free.
Are people hungry?
SPEAKER 1: No.
AUDIENCE: Why don't
you start from Maven?
Why did you write
it from scratch?
SPEAKER 2: Why didn't
you start from Maven?
I'm not enough of a
Java person, but I'll--
SPEAKER 1: Or grunt.
DAMIEN MARTIN-GUILLEREZ:
That's fun
because before joining Google,
I was actually using a lot Maven
and it failed to revert.
So Maven will run as
a test, for example.
It's super slow.
I wasn't here around the
times that Blaze was started.
As a part of Maven, like if you
do something more than Java,
you'll really feels
the pain of using it.
So Google was like is
[INAUDIBLE] so it's super
[? spruced ?] Java Go.
And so it needs some things
that works across language.
SPEAKER 1: You guys about
ready for some lunch?
We'll do one more question.
You're the last one.
Make it count.
AUDIENCE: One is about extending
the system by using plugins.
In what language will
you write these plugins?
SPEAKER 2: So what language do
I write a plugin for Bazel in?
DAMIEN MARTIN-GUILLEREZ:
This is a home language
that is called Skylark.
But it's actually
a subset of Python.
The reason it's
not fully Python,
it's for correctness issue.
We don't want to
overwrite our directory,
generate things that
have side effects.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And the last one is
about milestones.
Do you have some
public milestones
about releasing these two?
SPEAKER 2: So
repeat the question.
What are the-- are
there public milestones?
I think it's posted
on the website.
DAMIEN MARTIN-GUILLEREZ: Yes.
We have a public
[INAUDIBLE] map.
It's on our website.
We're about to
reach-- we're going
to announce 0.4 next week so if
you want to follow it, you can.
SPEAKER 2: And I want
to add one more thing.
One of the things we're
working on with the Dart team
is that there'll be
low-level Skylark
rules written in Skylark.
There's very good reason
it has its own language.
I should repeat that
because everyone's like,
why another language?
SPEAKER 1: Purely
functional subset of Python
sounds awesome.
SPEAKER 2: You want
guaranteed correctness,
you get hermeticness.
No one wants a
distributed build system
that does things incorrectly.
It messes up the caching
because we're all very sad.
But in the Dart
world, what we're
looking at is we'll
have low level Bazel
rules-- at least this
is our current plan,
we're working on it-- we'll
have low-level Bazel rules.
We'll write the Bazel.
And the idea is
then you can just
write Dart code and
configuration on top
to do your transformation,
and you'll just
call down to a Dart library and
say, cool, and write some YAML
and it will work.
[INAUDIBLE] Beck
saying, damn PM,
why are you making promises?
But we think we can do that.
DAMIEN MARTIN-GUILLEREZ:
It's not only for that.
I mean [INAUDIBLE]
language that we
wonder a lot of words
for various language
we have [? closer ?] compiles.
We have SAS, Rest, and we try
to [INAUDIBLE] so you can just
use them out of the box.
You don't have to
write your own.
[APPLAUSE]